he's going to answer the phone what's
his name his name
you go by caroline carrie carrie sorry
just say carrie don't you know how to
pronounce the name tan you're right
um okay i'm ready let me i'm going to
turn on my mother voice i give you
motherly vibes right yeah you don't no
but this is it you saw your daughter and
you should tell him that it's like no
yeah that's what i was just going to say
hi this is caroline's mother
you could be the father at some point
yeah i'll i'll tell you but what's his
name
all right you got to bleep out the name
jeremy when we air this
we're about to what he did he's proud of
it too he said he had a great time why
isn't it working i don't know
um yeah
no facetime
[Laughter]
yeah my podcast could never
oh my god just one chord
hello
hi
i'm so sorry to bother you um this is
caroline's mother do you have a moment
to speak
uh yeah what's up um
i i really do hate to break this to you
or talk to you about it it's just kind
of a weird conversation but she can't
come to the phone right now
um she's actually at the ucla
icu right now
and um
she had she had something going on with
her lip and she wasn't really expressing
to me what was kind of going on and it's
turned into this massive infection i'm
talking pus
blood
whole thing and she's
she's in the icu right now and she she
just let the doctor know that there
could have been some mishap
um
with you
okay i'm
yeah i'm not aware of that at all that's
really unfortunate um
she said something about a subaru
um
she said something about you guys where
you you were in a subaru you were like
in your car or something like that
um
and this happened i mean do you have any
stds
i no i don't and so i don't know what
that's about
are you sure
her father uh i mean hello
her i'm with her father and i i think
hello he wants to speak to you young man
yeah but i just wanted to give you no no
no no no
she's trying to calm me down and i'm not
calm down
what happened
yeah tell me what happened um
okay um
well i kissed caroline
uh for a little bit after our day
or you know during our day
um
but yeah i don't know i mean
this is more than a kiss
tell me what happened
well that's i mean that's all there is
to it it was and we were making out for
a little while but no this is more than
making out
you know what you've done
i just i have her phone here
and you said i hope your lip is okay i
see that text
what did you do to my daughter's lip
no
well
she said um
i don't know i mean we were just the
only reason i said that was because i
was just trying to
i don't know just be a little bit flirty
and she said
she cuz she made a comment while we were
kissing she was like oh my gosh um
like you're really gonna tell my husband
about comments our daughter made while
you two were kissing
i mean i don't know you were trying to
ask honey calm down calm down
this young man
has got to take some responsibility calm
calm down what did he do tell me what
you did sir own up to it
what did you do to my daughter's lip
i didn't do anything did you bite her i
just did you bite were there teeth
involved did you bite that's all i'm
asking did you bite my daughter
no
there was no teeth involved
whatsoever
all right i'm done with this
conversation i'm sorry guys
no there were no teeth involved
oh my god oh my god oh my god he lied uh
i was really i was where i thought we
were gonna tell him it was a prank but i
almost live for the fact that this man
is like shaking in his [ __ ] blue
train you call him back and tell him
[ __ ] no
he deserves a little hazing
you're really gonna bite sweet carolina
you know whatever little does he know
it's like [ __ ] howie mandel like that
is so funny that is like
him let's see how he reacts he'll
probably tell me to go [ __ ] off but i
did do something stupid what'd you do i
no i mean like he did something stupid
like he should know that he shouldn't
[ __ ] bite girls what do you mean
oh i'm the devil like when men are like
i would like out toxic any man i love
[ __ ] with men especially him it was a
prank and tell him that he's wrong yeah
i will
[Laughter]
still give him a bad [ __ ] city girl
period
hey
should we leave a voicemail hey pick up
the phone pick up the phone one more
time just you'll it'll be worth it for
you pick up the phone
pick up the phone
he can't hear uh it's not like an old
school
voicemail
i just went back to 1974.
he didn't have an answering machine
well wait till wait till his beeper goes
off
[Music]